president Trump's endorsement of the
controversial anti-malaria drug reached
new heights where he dropped this
bombshell I happen to be taking it I
happen to be taking it I'm taking
hydroxychloroquine right now yeah a
couple of weeks ago I started taking it
because I think it's gonna have heard a
lot of good stories and if it's not good
I'll tell you right I'm not gonna get
hurt by it it's been around for 40 years
from malaria for lupus for other things
I take it it was a dramatic development
in his push to promote this unproven
treatment for coronavirus as he well
knew I was just waiting to see your eyes
light up when I said this but you know
when I announced this but yeah I've
taken it for about a week and a half now
and I'm still here but some people are
not one study found hydroxychloroquine
caused an increased mortality rate in
coronavirus patients most of the ongoing
research has concluded that there's
simply no evidence that it works in
covert infections but the White House
physician confirmed the president is
taking it a letter reads after numerous
discussions he and I had regarding
evidence for and against the use of
hydroxychloroquine we concluded the
potential benefit from treatment
outweighs the relative risks it is
important to note the president has not
tested positive for corona virus nor
does he have symptoms
he is taking hydroxychloroquine to ward
off the virus despite warnings from the
Food and Drug Administration about heart
rhythm problems it was left up to the
usually unflinchingly loyal Fox News to
warn Americans against the president's
aggressive reckless push if you are in a
risky population here and you are taking
this as a preventive treatment to ward
off the virus or in a worst-case
scenario you are dealing with the virus
and you are in this vulnerable
population it will kill you
I cannot stress enough this will kill
you it's not the first time the
president has used his powerful platform
to tout improve
than potentially harmful remedies and
then I see the disinfectant where it
knocks it out in a minute one minute and
is there way we can do something like
that with hydroxychloroquine it's not
just the possible side effects causing
concern the millions of Americans who
rely on it for treatment of lupus and
rheumatoid arthritis could face more
shortages because of an inevitable new
surge in demand driven from the very top
Amanda Walker Sky News Washington